welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn wilshire host and our guest is
Karen sedo professor of geography and
urbanization at the Yale School of
Forestry and environmental studies her
research is on the human transformation
of land and the links between
urbanization global change and
sustainability a geographer by training
her research integrates remote sensing
field interviews and modeling methods to
study land change and urbanization
forecasts urban growth and examine the
environmental consequences of urban
expansion today we'll talk with her
about urbanization global change and
sustainability welcome professor Seto
thank you thanks for having sure so the
majority of your work focuses on China
and India why those two places well
China and India what one third one out
of every three persons who lives in an
urban area lives in either train enter
India okay and so the magnitude of the
urban demographic there is enormous
that's what's happening now or the
current situation but if you look into
the future over the next 20 to 30 years
both China and India will experience a
really large scale urban expansion both
in terms of the population and also in
terms of land development so it
represents both of these countries
really represent a large fraction of the
global urban population okay makes sense
so let's talk about how land expansion
expansion has happened in the past well
if you look at the classic literature
like urban economics or agricultural
economics cities expanded in the past
historically because of land prices
because of a concentration of people
moving into the city because of jobs
it's very locally based so cities
expanded as part of hinterland but
cities today in especially cities in
China and India
are expanding in a very very different
way like where the factors that are
driving their growth are more driven or
more driven from outside of the country
and not locally so you have things like
foreign direct investment now in China
and in India that shapes the development
of housing estates residential estates
and that's really different than what
happened 50 years ago or even a hundred
years ago how so well in the past it was
just much more local right and so it's
not only local investment national
investments me national investments
still make a difference and still matter
but increasingly what we see in China
and India is that international
investments have a really big impact and
they impact a lot of different things
they impact how people live in terms of
the kind of housing structure that they
want single-family homes are much more
predominant now in China than they were
20 years ago that's something that's a
much really brought about from
investments from overseas but also
Chinese going overseas and saying well
this is a kind of housing that we'd like
to have okay so with the population
growing are you finding our urban areas
are growing up in terms of you know
housing is growing up in terms of this
you know skyrise is that kind of thing
as well as moving out to countryside
well that's an interesting question
because so much of what I do is with
remote sensing and with remotes and say
we've been looking primarily on at the
expansion on the two-dimensional sphere
but recently we've been doing some work
with people at the University of New
Hampshire and using other types of
satellites we've been able to see that
cities are growing both outwards but
then also they're growing really upwards
and Chinese cities especially are
increasingly growing up words we don't
see the same trend elsewhere and that's
not an MD effort and not as much Indian
cities are relatively low rise and very
expensive and there are a lot of
different reasons for this some of which
have to do with a lot of it have to
was zoning and building regulations
interesting so why is it important to
look at this kind of stuff urban
expansion yeah well it depends on who
you talk to so if you talk to the
private sector they're really interested
in understanding where people will live
and how they will live because that
shapes consumption patterns where you're
going to sell cars we're home depot
should be or maybe starbucks yeah at all
marketing data oh absolutely right where
the next consumers will be concentrated
if you talk to Earth System scientists
and climate scientists there's a lot of
interest in understanding how urban
areas will expand because how cities
grow and where people commute and
they're commuting patterns affect things
like daily energy use through transport
the size of your house affects energy
use and all of that then affects
greenhouse gas emissions and climate
change another element of this is to on
a global scale and over the next 20 to
30 years we're going to see somewhere on
the order of 1 to 2 billion more people
in cities and so we're going to have to
build a lot of urban space to house all
these people if you think globally at
the biodiversity hotspots all the
farmland in the world you have to think
well where will these cities develop
will they impact and fragment
biodiversity hotspots will they affect
the most productive farm lands another
element of this from more Red Cross
perspective or humanitarian perspective
is people are moving into places that
are vulnerable to hazards sea level rise
and storm surges so being able to
forecast where cities will grow and how
they will grow will have a will be
important depending on whether you're
talking to the private sector or
humanitarian efforts so what are you
finding in your research how will cities
be growing how will I urbanization
expand in the future well what we're
finding is that over the last 20 years
the general trend worldwide is that
of a reduced density and so going into
the future I mean if we looked
historically cities were compact and
really dense places concentrated people
and concentrated activities but going
into the future what we're expecting to
see given the recent trends is that
these are relatively low density
expansive commuting car based
communities that many of these new
cities will be in low-lying zones humans
like to live near the coast and we like
to be on the coast and so are we still
talking China and India no globally so
we've done a forecast globally of urban
up expansion and we're seeing this trend
globally that we there are a lot of
cities concentrated by the water yes
that's right and that trend is not going
to change and but at the same time if we
look at trends and climate change in and
hurricanes and storm surges I mean it
basically means the confluence of
concentrated people with increase
episodes of climate hazards so let's
talk about your methodology for for a
minute you touched on it earlier but how
do you determine how things will grow so
a lot of this is are using satellite
data so these are satellites that are
launched by NASA uh-huh they're
relatively coarse scale data by that I
mean each pixel or each cell we're
looking at is about 30 meters so to the
American crowd that's about right it's
about a hundred feet 90 feet or so and
basically what we're looking at is for
each of these pixels we're looking
historically at how this cell has
changed was it farmland was it was it
forest and we're able to look at
historical patterns using the satellite
data with historical patterns of
population growth and economic growth so
we can develop these mathematical
relations of population density built up
density in order to forecast where urban
development will be
the future so a little bit off-topic how
do you get access to satellite
information so the NASA data many much
of these data are actually publicly
available so you can apply for a grad
you can buy them some of these data are
free other others require funding and
pretty much anyone can use these data
yeah ok let's talk sustainability for a
little bit in terms of the growth of
urbanization when you look forward you
know 10 years 20 years you know do you
grow concerned over the fact that you
know we are encroaching on forest fringe
and for instance and and other I would
say more environmental areas what are
you finding what are your thoughts well
the the literature in our own research
is mixed on this I mean it really
depends on a case-to-case basis one
thing that we don't we the scientific
community doesn't have a really good
handle on right now is what does global
urbanization mean for global
sustainability we have a lot of case
studies for many cities around the world
but we don't really have a really good
understanding of what will happen and
what are the the potential impacts some
of the potential impacts I've already
mentioned in terms of impacts on forest
and farmland and habitat loss certainly
the effects of urbanization on energy
use but on the other hand there's a lot
of research that shows that if you
concentrate people in urban areas it
actually reduces per capita energy and
material use in other words it's much
more resource-efficient to have people
concentrated in urban areas than it is
to spread them out all across the
countryside and if you think about the
concrete and steel fiber optics to wire
everybody up if they're in low-density
single-family homes versus and
concentrated places that's really really
quite different in terms of material use
right in terms of the population growth
in India and China you know how do you
think that will affect urbanization in
those countries well what we're seeing
is very different drivers of
urbanization in China and India in the
popular media we see that China and
India are often talked about as there is
though there are some monolithic joined
together type place but in fact they're
really different the patterns of
urbanization are very different and the
drivers are very different china during
the first half of the 20th century is is
is primarily a story of urban population
growth and large-scale urban
infrastructure development if you look
at the story of India it's very
different whereas the the story of India
is one where the urban population growth
is really going to take place during the
second half of this century so the
patterns the spatial patterns are also
going to be very different China has a
lot more large-scale city development
compared to what's happening in India
which is much more smaller scale okay
looking at the globe what places do you
anticipate will be growing of the most
or the fastest again China and India
perhaps or are there any other places in
the world africa africa so cities in
Africa will be growing pretty
significantly part of that is population
growth but also part of that is in the
the growth of economies and in Africa
things are starting to take off in
Africa any particular places in Africa
South Africa or you know perhaps more
centrally or the east coast we're seeing
at least in our models we're seeing that
on the western coast actually in places
like in Nigeria we're going to see a lot
of the smaller cities really expand out
mm-hmm okay and then lastly in terms of
against sustainability what do you think
that you know the biggest concerns are
going to be moving forward on a global
scale in terms of urbanization
well I think there are two different
types of sustainability questions from
more environmental perspective some of
the sustainability questions or around
resource use and energy what are the
resources required to build and operate
it's not just operating but building the
cities of tomorrow some of our most
recent models suggest that over the next
20 years we're going to have an area
three times the size of Spain be
developed into cities so that's a huge
amount of resources and in terms of
operating those cities those cities are
going to need a lot of resources and
energy to maintain them so on the
environmental side there are big
questions around resource and material
use I think on the social side there are
really big questions and uncertainties
around the social sustainability of
cities there are many cities in China
and India where traffic congestion
pollution a lack of social cohesion
violence are really big issues and it's
unclear how these cities will continue
to evolve over the next 20 to 30 years
not just those in China but ones in
Africa as well and so that is I think
another issue in terms of thinking about
sustainability of cities and of
urbanization do you have any words of
wisdom perhaps or any cautionary words
for places that will be growing in terms
of what to do or what not to do perhaps
well it's always easier to come up with
what not to do and what you should do
and and one of the things that we've
learned is that the the cities or the
urbanizing places that are the most
functioning both environmentally and
socially are ones that develop because
or developed in a way because their
leaders had a vision had a vision of
what that place could be as opposed to
really thinking should very very short
term it's it's clear from the research
that cities are sites of innovation
there are places that are very create
but that doesn't happen spontaneously
and and that there are certain elements
of the of the city that can nurture this
or can become obstacles and so a large
challenge I think going to the future is
to think about a vision for a place and
to have the resources to bring those
pieces together to meet to really to
achieve that vision good proper planning
well you know interestingly enough not
always really really so planning I think
there are many examples where planning
has actually failed well too much
planning part of what makes exciting
cities exciting is that that element of
chaos that element of uncertainty if you
think about the cities that you like
going to I would imagine that your
favorite cities include having you where
you can walk around and discover right
get discover new restaurants or coffee
shops sometimes the most well-planned
places are two punctual to everything in
an order thing right right yeah I can
think of a couple of examples you know
pro planning and then not pro planning
you know the city i grew up in for
instance I when I think about the city I
say wow people could have planned this
so much better but I guess to your point
sometimes it doesn't work yeah I think
it's a matter of finding that right
balance of top-down and bottom-up right
yes well that's hard to come by
unfortunately I think sometimes yeah
well this has been fascinating thank you
so much for being here with us today and
sharing some of your work oh my pleasure
to thank you for having me for more
information about professor Seto and her
research please visit our website at
yale edu slash mcmillan report be sure
to join us again for another episode of
the macmillan report made possible
through funding from the Whitney and
Betty Macmillan Center for International
and area studies at Yale
you